Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. 2018 was the worst year the U.S. stock market has seen since 2008, back when we were in the throes of the Great Recession. If the stock market is giving you anxiety and making you want to jump ship, you'll want to hear the advice of our guest on this episode. Dr. Frank Murtha is a psychologist by training and co-founder of my husband. Market Psych, a consulting firm to the financial industry, where he uses applied investing psychology to the financial services industry. Later, I'll share an email from a listener about our recent podcast on keeping civility alive at holiday gatherings. If you have any comments, questions,
您好，欢迎收听美国心理学会推出的双周播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。2018年是美国股市自2008年大衰退时期以来表现最糟糕的一年。如果股市让你感到焦虑，让你想要撤资，那么你一定会想听听我们本期嘉宾的建议。弗兰克·默萨博士是一位受过专业训练的心理学家，也是Market Psych的联合创始人，这是一家为金融行业提供咨询的公司，他将应用投资心理学引入了金融服务领域。稍后，我将分享一位听众发来的电子邮件，内容关于我们最近一期关于在节日聚会上保持文明的播客。如果您有任何意见、问题，
or ideas for us, email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-R. We'd love to hear from you. Now let's welcome Dr. Murtha. Hi, Caitlin. How you doing? I'm doing great. It's wonderful to have you on our show today. Now let's start with the current state of the U.S. stock market. The volatile market has made many investors nervous about the year to come, and it's probably deter potential investors from jumping in. So what's your take on what's happening? People often refer to the markets as climbing a wall of worry. And I think that we climbed it so slowly and for so long, without looking down, that when we finally had a chance, we said, boy, we're up really high right now. So if you take
或想法，请发送电子邮件至K-Luna@APA.org。拼写是K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-R。我们非常期待您的来信。现在让我们欢迎默萨博士。你好，凯特琳。你好吗？我很好。今天能请你来我们的节目真是太棒了。现在让我们从美国股市的现状谈起。动荡的市场让许多投资者对未来一年感到紧张，这可能也会阻止潜在投资者入市。那么，你对目前发生的事情有什么看法？人们常说市场是在“忧虑之墙”上攀爬。我认为我们攀爬得太慢，时间太长，以至于没有向下看，当我们终于有机会看时，我们说，天哪，我们现在爬得太高了。所以如果你考虑到
That element, as well as some of the political stuff that's going on and some of the legitimate concerns people have of the state of the world, it's a recipe for volatility. And what does the psychological research say about why markets go from being stable, to going well, to being suddenly volatile like we just experienced? A lot of it boils down to herd behavior. You know, what happens is that a few key people begin making moves. other people follow and it just becomes a cascade. This sort of thing really only happens after there's been a run-up. People talk about volatility a lot in the stock market, but they only really seem to care about it when the stock market's going down.
这一因素，以及正在发生的一些政治事件和人们对世界现状的一些合理担忧，这就是动荡的根源。心理学研究对于市场为何从稳定、运行良好突然变得像我们刚刚经历的那样动荡有什么解释吗？很大程度上归结为群体行为。你知道，发生的情况是，少数关键人物开始采取行动，其他人随之跟进，这就变成了一场连锁反应。这种事情通常只发生在市场上涨之后。人们经常谈论股市的波动，但他们似乎只有在股市下跌时才真正关心它。
When the stock market's going up, people don't seem to mind volatility so much. So when scary things like what we've experienced happen, especially when most people investing today can remember the, abject despair and terror of the banking crisis 10 years earlier. It's bound to, you know, have people react like this. Yeah, it does make me nervous. I mean, watching my retirement go down is a little scary. You know, I know I'm many years away from retirement, but still, it's like, whoa, you see tens of thousands of dollars lost. Like, you know, whoa. And for people who are close to retirement, that's got to be really scary. When you say that, it makes me think of that old joke
当股市上涨时，人们似乎并不太在意波动。所以，当像我们所经历的那样可怕的事情发生时，特别是当今天大多数投资者还记得10年前银行业危机带来的极度绝望和恐惧时，人们必然会做出这样的反应。是的，这确实让我感到紧张。我的意思是，看着我的退休金缩水有点可怕。我知道我离退休还有很多年，但即便如此，那种感觉就像是，哇，你看到数万美元就这样没了。就像，你知道，哇。对于那些临近退休的人来说，那一定非常可怕。当你这么说时，让我想起了那个老笑话，
of somebody who goes to the doctor and they say to the doctor doc my elbow hurts when I do this and the doc says don't do that and so one of the things that's actually really key for people when it comes to managing their anxiety
有人去看医生，他对医生说：“医生，我做这个动作时手肘会痛。”医生说：“那就别做那个动作。”所以，当人们想要管理焦虑时，一个非常关键的方法是，
is to try as much as possible to pay less attention to what's going on because if you get drawn into a short-term focus and you find yourself following daily maybe many times daily if you find yourself checking you are going to begin to miss the big picture and start seeing trees and not seeing a forest. And it's really a recipe.
尽可能少去关注正在发生的事情。因为如果你陷入短期关注，发现自己每天甚至多次查看市场，你就会开始忽略大局，只见树木不见森林。这真的是一个秘诀。
It's a recipe for disaster, long-term investing. And here's the thing. There's so much information available. It's so easy. And I do it too, by the way. You just log on, check. I wonder how I'm doing today. Yeah.
这是一个长期投资灾难的秘诀。问题在于，现在可获取的信息太多了。这太容易了。顺便说一句，我自己也会这样做。你只是登录，查看一下。我想知道我今天表现如何。是的。
The day-by-day stuff is less important than over time. Oh, yeah. And it's right there. It's available. It's important. And I mean, honestly, when I first got into this business psychology, you know, the business of psychology of investing, investing had just begun going mainstream. It used to be something for, you know, in people's minds, kind of stuffed shirts on Wall Street
日复一日的波动不如长期表现重要。哦，是的。而且它就在那里，触手可及。这很重要。我的意思是，老实说，当我刚进入这个商业心理学领域时，你知道，投资心理学这个行业，投资才刚刚开始成为主流。在人们的印象中，它曾经是属于那些，你知道，华尔街上那些死板的人，
who possibly smoked pipes and planned world affairs and rooms with a lot of mahogany and leather and stuff like that. That's all changed. Everybody's an investor now. And so now that it's gone mainstream and all this information has been. made available. It's a blessing and a curse. Yeah, absolutely. Sometimes too information is too much. And
他们可能抽着烟斗，在摆满红木家具和皮革制品的房间里策划世界大事。这一切都变了。现在每个人都是投资者。所以，既然它已经成为主流，所有这些信息都变得触手可及。这既是福也是祸。是的，绝对是。有时信息太多了。而且，
later on we're going to delve into more of the individual investing. But first, I want to talk about your background a little more because I think it's really interesting. I'm sure you've been told this as well. So you have a PhD in counseling psychology and originally wanted to be a children's therapist. And now you're the co-founder of Market Psych.
稍后我们将深入探讨个人投资。但首先，我想更多地了解一下你的背景，因为我觉得这非常有趣。我相信别人也一定这样对你说过。你拥有咨询心理学博士学位，最初想成为一名儿童治疗师。而现在你是Market Psych的联合创始人。
So how did you make that change from potential children's therapist to co-founder of a company? I would say I made that change slowly over time and exhausting many alternatives along the way. I love working with kids. What I found was it really ended up ultimately taking a very emotional toll on me. I loved helping kids, but I found that I wasn't always able to have the effect I wanted. I'd bring that home with me. And so I look for other populations, other ways in which I could do it. And I found the same
那么，你是如何从潜在的儿童治疗师转变为公司联合创始人的呢？我想我是随着时间的推移，在尝试了许多其他选择后慢慢做出这一改变的。我喜欢和孩子们一起工作。但我发现，这最终对我造成了很大的情感负担。我喜欢帮助孩子，但我发现我并不总能达到我想要的效果。我会把这种情绪带回家。所以我寻找其他群体，寻找其他可以实现目标的方式。我发现同样的情况，
thing over and over again. Wonderful, wonderful work done by counseling psychologists. It made, it had an effect on me that really drained me a bit emotionally. But I still wanted to help people. I still wanted to apply what I knew and help people's lives be better. And so I began to gravitate more towards consulting work. And around that time, and this was back in the late 90s, you remember the late 90s? The markets were booming and investing had gone mainstream. Back in the late 90s, I began to get interested in it, and it was fascinating to me. The psychology of investing was fascinating to me. And I had these friends from college. And a lot of them were Wall Street guys. And I talked to them. And I was the psychology guy, and they were the Wall Street guys.
一次又一次地发生。咨询心理学家所做的非常棒的工作，对我产生了一种让我情感上感到有些枯竭的影响。但我仍然想帮助别人。我仍然想应用我所知道的知识，让人们的生活变得更好。所以我开始更多地转向咨询工作。大约在那个时候，那是90年代末，你还记得90年代末吗？市场繁荣，投资成为主流。在90年代末，我开始对它产生兴趣，它让我着迷。投资心理学让我着迷。我有一些大学朋友，他们中很多人是华尔街的人。我和他们交谈。我是心理学专家，而他们是华尔街专家。
And they'd say, you know, they'd make some observation about the market. And then I'd make an observation that a psychologist would make. And they'd go, oh, yeah, Frank, you know, that's a case of market psychology, though. That's not really, you know, the numbers. And they tended to concentrate on more concrete things. And I thought to myself, well, it's all market psychology. That's what a market is. A market is nothing but the aggregate psychology of its participants. And I began to think this is really fascinating. And it really got in my blood a little bit.
他们会说，你知道，他们会对市场做出一些观察。然后我会做出心理学家会做的观察。他们会说，哦，是的，弗兰克，你知道，那是市场心理学的一个案例，那并不是，你知道，数字本身。他们倾向于关注更具体的事情。我心想，好吧，这全是市场心理学。市场就是这样。市场不过是其参与者总体的心理表现。我开始认为这真的很迷人。它确实有点融入了我的血液。
And so I pursued a dissertation on gambling and cognitive errors made by gamblers because if you're interested in the world of finance, there isn't exactly a very clear bridge from the world of psychology. And gambling and the psychology of gambling seemed to be it. So I set out to work with kids and help them integrate into the classroom better, and now I'm doing something completely different. But you're still using psychology in both of those fields, what I think is absolutely fascinating that you use psychology and what you do in your current job. And money and feelings seem world apart, but you've said they're inextricably linked. So can you share some examples about how you've shown your corporate clients the importance of understanding their client's emotions?
所以我攻读了关于赌博和赌徒认知错误的论文，因为如果你对金融世界感兴趣，心理学世界并没有一个非常清晰的桥梁。而赌博和赌博心理学似乎就是那个桥梁。所以我原本打算和孩子们一起工作，帮助他们更好地融入课堂，而现在我做的事情完全不同。但你在两个领域都在运用心理学，我认为你将心理学运用到目前的工作中是非常迷人的。金钱和情感看起来是两个完全不同的世界，但你说它们是密不可分的。那么，你能分享一些例子，说明你是如何向企业客户展示理解客户情绪的重要性吗？
Sure, sure. You know, I think that financial advisors, and I do a lot of work with financial advisors, the people who manage clients money. And so, you know, they work with money, but they're also working with people and their feelings. And one of the things that I think the people in financial advising can learn from the field of counseling psychology is that people really tend to want to jump to solutions. You know, you're an advisor and you're in the room with somebody. and you already have in mind what the remedy is to their issue, to their problem, you may even find yourself shutting down that person's emotion. Maybe they're a little bit, maybe they're a little bit anxious. And so instead of hearing that person out, that client, what you say is, oh, no, there's no need to worry. And then you have your explanation. Or maybe they're feeling a little bit down, a little sad. And so you say, oh, no, cheer up. It's going to be fine. the tendency to want to remove the emotion from the equation and get right down to the solution
当然，当然。你知道，我认为财务顾问，我与很多财务顾问合作，也就是那些管理客户资金的人。所以，你知道，他们处理的是金钱，但他们也在与人和他们的感受打交道。我认为财务顾问可以从咨询心理学领域学到的一点是，人们确实倾向于急于寻找解决方案。你知道，你是一名顾问，你和某人在一起，你心里已经有了解决他们问题的办法，你甚至可能发现自己在压制那个人的情绪。也许他们有点，也许他们有点焦虑。所以，你没有倾听那个人的心声，没有倾听那个客户，而是说，哦，不，没必要担心。然后你给出了你的解释。或者也许他们感到有点沮丧，有点难过。所以你说，哦，不，振作起来。一切都会好起来的。这种想要从等式中剔除情绪并直接寻求解决方案的倾向，
is a problem in the field, I think. Because I like to say financial advisors don't say the wrong things. They say the right things before the client is ready to hear them. And anybody who's done clinical work can appreciate how important it is to build that relationship, to get the client into a position where they feel heard, where they feel understood, where you're actually able to have that effect. So there's a lot more listening goes into this field than most people would believe. Yeah, and really also acknowledging how people are feeling about their investment decisions,
我认为是该领域的一个问题。因为我喜欢说，财务顾问说的并不是错话。他们只是在客户准备好倾听之前就说了正确的话。任何做过临床工作的人都能体会到建立那种关系是多么重要，让客户处于一种感到被倾听、被理解的状态，这样你才能真正产生那种效果。所以这个领域需要的倾听比大多数人想象的要多得多。是的，而且真正承认人们对他们的投资决策的感受，
I think is important too. Because, I mean, sometimes I think, like you said, people, it's not as though financial advisors say the wrong thing, but they're also trying to go into solution mode, which sometimes, as you know, as a psychologist, and I know from, you know, working at APA, that doesn't necessarily always help to go into solution mode. sometimes you just want someone to acknowledge how you're feeling, okay, you're feeling nervous, at least in the bridge to offering a solution. So I'm sure it's probably a new way of thinking for your clients, how to approach their work.
我认为也很重要。因为，我的意思是，有时我想，就像你说的，人们，并不是说财务顾问说错了话，但他们也试图进入解决方案模式，有时，正如你所知，作为一名心理学家，我也从在APA的工作中了解到，进入解决方案模式并不一定总是有帮助。有时你只是想让别人承认你的感受，好吧，你感到紧张，至少在提供解决方案之前要有一个过渡。所以我相信这对你的客户来说可能是一种新的思维方式，如何处理他们的工作。
Yeah, you know, I agree 100%, Caitlin. And it reminds me of this cartoon. It's a cartoon of a man, and he's in a kind of a comfy chair. And you can see he's at the edge of a cliff. And he's kind of looking out down over the cliff. And a woman is next to him, presumably his wife. don't want to stereotype, but that's kind of what it seems. And she says to him, is this guy, he's kind of like staring down over the cliff in his comfy chair. And she says, if you want to
是的，你知道，我100%同意，凯特琳。这让我想起了一幅漫画。漫画里有一个男人，他坐在舒适的椅子上。你可以看到他在悬崖边上。他正盯着悬崖下方看。旁边有一个女人，大概是他的妻子。我不想刻板印象，但看起来就是这样。她对他说，这个家伙，他就像坐在舒适的椅子上盯着悬崖下面看。她说，如果你想
have a positive outlook, you're going to have to turn your chair around, Walter. And it's great. And I use that and it's cute and people get a chuckle. But I go, okay, what is the way that you get somebody to turn the chair around, right? Is it to say, no, turn your chair around, view it this other way. You're seeing it wrong. I'm disagreeing. with you and telling you the right way to see it. Yeah. No, that's not how it works. What you do is you pull up your chair next to Walter.
拥有积极的展望，你就必须把椅子转过来，沃尔特。这太棒了。我用这个例子，它很可爱，人们会会心一笑。但我会说，好吧，你让别人把椅子转过来的方法是什么呢？是说，不，把你的椅子转过来，从这个角度看。你看到的角度不对。我不同意你的看法，并告诉你正确的看法吗？不，那不是它的运作方式。你要做的是把你的椅子拉到沃尔特旁边。
You look at what Walter, or whoever it may be, is looking at. And you go, what are you looking at? What do you see? Wow. And you talk about it. And you let them understand. You understand and you see it too. And if you do that and you work with that person in that way,
你看看沃尔特，或者无论那个人是谁，正在看什么。然后你说，你在看什么？你看到了什么？哇。然后你们讨论它。你让他们理解。你理解并你也看到了。如果你这样做，并以那种方式与那个人合作，
then you buy yourself the ability to say, all right, what if we turn our chair around? What if we look at what's going on behind us? But you can't do that by forcing the issue. So it's a lot of good listening, recognizing the emotions that people are feeling. And, I mean, it gets back to Carl Rogers, you know. I mean, if financial advisors would watch Carl Rogers videos or read his books, I guarantee you, not only would they be helping their clients more, they'd increase their book
那么你就赢得了说“好吧，如果我们把椅子转过来会怎样？如果我们看看我们身后发生了什么会怎样？”的能力。但你不能通过强迫来做到这一点。所以这需要大量的倾听，识别人们正在感受的情绪。而且，我的意思是，这回到了卡尔·罗杰斯，你知道。我的意思是，如果财务顾问能观看卡尔·罗杰斯的视频或阅读他的书，我保证，他们不仅会更多地帮助他们的客户，还会极大地增加他们的业务量。
of business dramatically. That's fascinating. And earlier, before we started our conversation, we talked about some of the stereotypes of people in the finance day traders, financial advisors. And what came to mind for me with some of the characters in the big short, you know, and those stereotypes generally are not really that positive. You know, they're chaotic, you know, New York Stock Exchange floor, people running around or, you know, those wealthy investment bankers with these huge offices over Central Park with mahogany furniture. you know, other people might think about Bernie Madoff, who's the former investment advisor who went to prison for creating a massive Ponzi scheme. And so, you know, we do know that stereotypes are not fair and they're really not helpful, but, you know, those ideas likely do persist in the minds of many people. So do you think that Market Sykes approach helps combat those stereotypes?
这太迷人了。早些时候，在我们开始谈话之前，我们谈到了一些金融领域人们的刻板印象，比如日内交易员、财务顾问。我脑海中浮现的是《大空头》中的一些角色，你知道，那些刻板印象通常并不那么正面。你知道，他们是混乱的，你知道，纽约证券交易所大厅，人们跑来跑去，或者，你知道，那些在中央公园上方拥有巨大办公室、配有红木家具的富有投资银行家。你知道，其他人可能会想到伯尼·麦道夫，那位因制造庞氏骗局而入狱的前投资顾问。所以，你知道，我们确实知道刻板印象是不公平的，而且真的没有帮助，但是，你知道，这些想法很可能在许多人的脑海中挥之不去。那么你认为Market Psych的方法有助于消除这些刻板印象吗？
Well, yeah, first of all, those stereotypes for, you know, they're absolutely out there. I can tell you in my experience, people who behave in such a way are a very, very small minority. Most of the people in this business are in it for the right reasons. But obviously, it only takes a couple of high-profile people to change the impression of an industry like that. As far as market site goes, I hope what we're doing is helping people recognize that in order to serve their clients better and help those people, those clients, live the lives they want to live. You really do have to understand who they are, be able to show that you understand and respect that, and have better, deeper conversations about why they're doing this and what they want the results to be. But, you know, honestly, people in the financial fields are just not trained this way.
嗯，是的，首先，那些刻板印象，你知道，它们绝对存在。我可以告诉你，根据我的经验，行为那样的人只是极少数。这个行业里的大多数人都是出于正确的理由才从事这个行业的。但显然，只需要几个高调的人就能改变人们对这样一个行业的印象。就Market Psych而言，我希望我们所做的是帮助人们认识到，为了更好地服务客户并帮助那些人，那些客户，过上他们想要的生活，你确实必须了解他们是谁，能够表现出你理解并尊重这一点，并就他们为什么这样做以及他们希望结果是什么进行更好、更深入的对话。但是，你知道，老实说，金融领域的人并没有受过这种训练。
I mean, the way people in the psychology field are trained and the way people in the financial field are trained, there's only lately has there been any crossover. I mean, they were just parallel lives that lived next to each other and had no idea. you know, the next door, who their next door neighbor was for years. Right. I mean, I'm sure maybe some, if you're going to school for economics or finance, business, whatnot, it maybe would be helpful to have some psychology courses in the mix, at least, to say, okay, let's get in the minds of people who you're working with. Because, again, I mean, their job depends on clients and their client success.
我的意思是，心理学领域的人受到的训练方式和金融领域的人受到的训练方式，直到最近才有一些交叉。我的意思是，他们只是平行生活在彼此旁边，却不知道，你知道，隔壁，多年来他们的邻居是谁。对。我的意思是，我敢肯定，也许有些人，如果你去学校学习经济学或金融、商业之类的，在课程中加入一些心理学课程可能会有帮助，至少可以说，好吧，让我们进入你所合作的人的头脑中。因为，再说一次，我的意思是，他们的工作取决于客户和客户的成功。
Yeah, you know, it's interesting. There's a field out there that's gotten a lot of buzz lately. It's called behavioral finance. And the reason it's called behavioral finance is because the finance people found it first and not the psychology people. Otherwise, it would have been called like financial psychology or investing psychology. Because that's what it is. It's just taking a look at the emotions and cognitions that lead to financial decision-making and financial behavior. And it's a surprisingly new field.
是的，你知道，这很有趣。有一个领域最近引起了很多关注。它被称为行为金融学。它之所以被称为行为金融学，是因为金融界的人先发现了它，而不是心理学界的人。否则，它会被称为金融心理学或投资心理学。因为这就是它的本质。它只是审视导致财务决策和财务行为的情绪和认知。这是一个令人惊讶的新领域。
You could even say that there's been behavioral finance books written. in the past, but they just didn't have a shared vocabulary. So, yeah, absolutely. This is, this is really important stuff. Yeah, and I want to shift more towards individual investors. So you and your co-founder, Richard Peterson, who's a medical doctor, which is also very interesting, wrote a book a few years ago called Market Psych, How to Manage Your Fear and Build Your Investor Identity, which you told me was named one of the best financial books of the year by Kiplinger's personal finance. So can you explain what an investor identity is? Sure. An investor identity is an understanding of who you are as it pertains to your approach to investing. So it encompasses things such as,
你甚至可以说，过去也写过行为金融学的书，但它们只是缺乏一个共同的词汇表。所以，是的，绝对是这样。这确实是非常重要的内容。是的，我想更多地转向个人投资者。所以你和你的联合创始人理查德·彼得森（Richard Peterson）——他是一位医学博士，这也很有趣——几年前写了一本书叫《市场心理学：如何管理你的恐惧并建立你的投资者身份》（Market Psych, How to Manage Your Fear and Build Your Investor Identity），你告诉我这本书被《吉普林个人理财》（Kiplinger's Personal Finance）评为年度最佳金融书籍之一。那么你能解释一下什么是投资者身份吗？当然。投资者身份是对你作为投资者在投资方法上的一种自我认知。所以它涵盖了诸如以下内容：
what are my values? What do I care about as an investor? What are my motivations? What's going on under the surface that's driving me to do this? What's my investing personality? One of the things that MarketSyke does is we actually have modified personality. test based on the Neo that take a look at the five personality factors and how they pertain to people's investing habits. Another thing, another part of an identity, which is actually really, really important, is understanding what your strengths are and what understanding what your weaknesses are. Without that, you're going to, well, let's put it this way, it makes your job an awful lot harder. You know, a thing about this subject, almost everybody will
我的价值观是什么？作为投资者，我在乎什么？我的动机是什么？在表面之下是什么在驱动我做这件事？我的投资个性是什么？《市场心理学》所做的事情之一就是我们实际上修改了基于大五人格（Neo）的个性测试，观察这五种人格因素以及它们如何与人们的投资习惯相关联。另一件事，身份的另一个组成部分，实际上非常非常重要，那就是了解你的优势是什么，了解你的弱点是什么。没有这一点，你会……嗯，我们换个说法，这会让你的工作变得困难得多。你知道，关于这个主题，几乎每个人都会
tell you that in order to be a good investor, you really have to know yourself. And that's true. But then most people don't actually go through the necessary work to figure out what that would look like. When it comes to investing, a lot of it boils down to what makes a good fit. I'll give you an example, sort of an analogy. Getting in good financial shape is a lot like getting in good physical shape. Now, if you wanted to get in good physical shape, you'd need a diet, an eating plan. And if you go online or go to a bookstore, if people still go to bookstores, you'll see there's so many choices out there. And the thing that makes a little challenging is basically they'd all work. I mean, quacks, quacks aside, all of those plans would work if you
告诉你，为了成为一名优秀的投资者，你真的必须了解自己。这是事实。但大多数人并没有真正去做必要的工作来弄清楚那会是什么样子。当谈到投资时，很多事情归结为什么是合适的。我给你举个例子，算是一个类比。保持良好的财务状况就像保持良好的身体状况一样。现在，如果你想保持良好的身体状况，你需要一个饮食计划。如果你上网或去书店——如果人们还去书店的话——你会发现外面有太多的选择。而让事情变得有点挑战性的是，基本上它们都有效。我的意思是，撇开庸医不谈，所有这些计划如果
follow them. So how do you choose? How do you choose the right way to go about things? And the answer is, well, you don't choose the plan that in theory would work. You choose the one that works best for you, the plan you can best follow, the same way you would if you were trying to get in better shape. And I think you can't really do that until you take a good look at who you are, you know, and figure that out first. That's the key. So is that things like looking at your spending habits or like your values with money? Like is that what can you explain what that would be a little bit more? Like when you're looking at your own spending habits or saving habits or is it life goals? Yes. That's all part of that.
你遵循它们，都会有效。那么你如何选择呢？你如何选择正确的方式来处理事情？答案是，嗯，你不会选择理论上有效的计划。你选择最适合你的那个，你最能坚持下去的计划，就像你试图改善身体状况时所做的一样。我认为在你真正审视自己是谁之前，你无法真正做到这一点，你知道，先弄清楚这一点。这是关键。那么这是否包括审视你的消费习惯或你对金钱的价值观之类的事情？比如，你能解释一下那会是什么吗？比如当你审视自己的消费习惯或储蓄习惯，或者人生目标时？是的。那都是其中的一部分。
all part of the picture. I tend to focus less on personal finance and things like your spending habits and more on investing, you know, in terms of what are you, you know, wealth creation for your future with goals in mind, financial planning. That's where I tend to spend most of my focus. But yeah, I mean, all of those things definitely factor into it. I mean, I'll tell you this. I think this is an important way of looking at the investing process. And I think it's massively underappreciated, and I don't know if I've ever heard anybody else really think of it this way, but the biggest factor in investing is peer pressure. I mean that, absolutely, and I mean that quite literally.
都是整体的一部分。我倾向于较少关注个人理财和消费习惯之类的事情，而更多地关注投资，你知道，就你而言，你知道，为了你的未来而创造财富，心中有目标，财务规划。那是我倾向于投入大部分精力的地方。但是的，我的意思是，所有这些事情肯定都包含在内。我的意思是，我会告诉你这个。我认为这是一种看待投资过程的重要方式。而且我认为它被严重低估了，我不知道我是否听过其他人真正这样想，但投资中最大的因素是同伴压力。我是认真的，绝对是，而且我是字面意思上的。
If you think about, you know, a person listening to this podcast, they probably have some money invested, you know, 401K or a retirement plan, and they're thinking of themselves, okay, I'm going to invest this money. But everybody else who's investing is your peer. We're all peers. Now, how do you know if you like an investment? What drives whether something goes up in price and is a good investment or down? It's the extent to which other people like it.
如果你想到，你知道，一个听这个播客的人，他们可能投资了一些钱，你知道，401K或退休计划，他们心里想，好吧，我要投资这笔钱。但所有其他正在投资的人都是你的同伴。我们都是同伴。现在，你怎么知道你是否喜欢一项投资？是什么驱动了某样东西价格上涨并成为一项好的投资，还是下跌？这取决于其他人喜欢它的程度。
So if other people like an investment, your peers quite literally like it, it becomes more attractive because it rises in value and it causes you to want to like it. And it works in reverse too. And so overcoming peer pressure in investing is really the same way we overcome peer pressure growing up, peer pressure in our lives. Going back, I'm searching the memory banks here, but it reminds me of Erickson and his psychosocial stages. In teens, what's the stage?
所以如果其他人喜欢一项投资，你的同伴确实喜欢它，它就会变得更有吸引力，因为它价值上升，并导致你想喜欢它。反之亦然。因此，克服投资中的同伴压力，实际上和我们成长过程中克服同伴压力、生活中克服同伴压力是一样的。回想一下，我正在搜索记忆库，但这让我想起了埃里克森（Erickson）和他的心理社会发展阶段。在青少年时期，是什么阶段？
It's identity versus role confusion. The main psychosocial task of an adolescent is to figure out who the heck they are. And that's what's happening with investors. Most investors are chronologically adults. They've lived long enough. They've massed some money. But as far as their development as investors, they're really. adolescence and I don't say that in a pejorative fashion. They don't know who they are. They
是身份认同对角色混乱。青少年主要的心理社会任务是弄清楚他们到底是谁。这就是投资者身上正在发生的事情。大多数投资者在时间上是成年人。他们活得足够久，积累了一些钱。但就他们作为投资者的发展而言，他们实际上是青少年，我这样说并没有贬义。他们不知道自己是谁。他们
know enough to be dangerous, but not enough to really know what to do with their money. So they kind of look around and they go, what are other people doing? What are the markets doing? What did my brother-in-law tell me at that Fourth of July barbecue? That's the natural thing. So in order to combat that, you have to figure out who you are just like when you were a teenager. And you said, you know what? I kind of don't feel the need to go along with the crowd so much. I know what I like. I know what I don't like. I know what my goals are professionally and personally. And I'm going to go after them. And it really gives you the ability to resist the storm. It gives you an anchor in that storm out there of investing because it's really, really hard if you don't know who you are. And you
知道得足以让自己陷入危险，但不足以真正知道如何处理他们的钱。所以他们环顾四周，心想，别人在做什么？市场在做什么？我姐夫在那个国庆烧烤会上跟我说了什么？这是自然而然的事情。所以为了对抗这一点，你必须像青少年时期一样弄清楚你是谁。你说，你知道吗？我不太觉得有必要随大流。我知道我喜欢什么。我知道我不喜欢什么。我知道我在职业和个人方面的目标是什么。我要去追求它们。这确实给了你抵御风暴的能力。它给了你在投资风暴中的一个锚，因为如果你不知道自己是谁，那真的、真的很难。而且你
will get blown this way and that by the market. So for me, it really boils down to doing the work necessary to figure out all the aspects of an investor identity so you can overcome market prayer pressure and invest in a way that's right for you. Do you think that might come down to just like being a teenager, is that come down to being self-conscious and worried about what other people think and like if I don't follow what other people are doing, I'm going to make a bad financial decision? I think that can be part of it. I think that can be part of it. I think a lot of it boils down to a lack of confidence and not really having a clear sense of purpose.
会被市场吹得东倒西歪。所以对我来说，这真的归结为做必要的工作来弄清楚投资者身份的所有方面，这样你就可以克服市场同伴压力，并以适合你的方式进行投资。你认为这可能归结为仅仅像个青少年一样，这是否归结为自我意识过强，担心别人怎么想，比如如果我不跟随别人正在做的事情，我会做出错误的财务决定？我认为这可能是其中的一部分。我认为这可能是其中的一部分。我认为很多事情归结为缺乏自信，并没有真正明确的目标感。
Yeah, so those two things are really important to, I guess that's where it comes to the importance of understanding your investor identity and seeking out information and seeking out expert help is probably helpful for building your confidence because if you're going into it and without any knowledge, you might not be making the best decisions. Is that correct? Absolutely. You know, you said a lot of important things there. I do always think that it is best not to do this completely on your own. I'm not saying that you need to have a financial advisor, but I do think you need to have other opinions, experts, if nothing else, just to bounce your own ideas off of, to help keep you on the right path. You also have to do the work it really pays. Do the work to understand a balance sheet, understand some of the basics of investing, because otherwise you're really operating in a world that, you know, it's like me going
是的，所以这两件事对于，我想这就是理解你的投资者身份以及寻求信息和寻求专家帮助的重要性所在，这可能有助于建立你的自信，因为如果你在没有任何知识的情况下进入这个领域，你可能做不出最好的决定。这是正确的吗？绝对正确。你知道，你在那里说了许多重要的事情。我确实一直认为最好不要完全独自做这件事。我并不是说你需要有一位财务顾问，但我确实认为你需要有其他意见、专家，即使只是为了交流你自己的想法，帮助你保持在正确的道路上。你还必须做这项工作，它确实有回报。做这项工作去理解资产负债表，理解投资的一些基础知识，否则你真的在一个世界里运作，你知道，这就像我进入
into the mechanics. You know, they tell me I got a problem with my engine and they mention, oh, oh, you're, you know, you're garbage. I don't know what's going on. I'm at their mercy. You don't want to be at the mercy of other people. It doesn't take that much to get yourself up to at least cruising altitude where you have the necessary knowledge. And then lastly, I think taking a good look at yourself as an investor.
机械维修。你知道，他们告诉我我的引擎有问题，他们提到，哦，哦，你的，你知道，你的垃圾。我不知道发生了什么。我任由他们摆布。你不想任由别人摆布。让自己达到至少巡航高度，拥有必要的知识，并不需要太多。最后，我认为审视一下作为投资者的自己。
What works for you? Not just understanding what the numbers are. And so your book also has a whole chapter about managing investing emotions. So what do you tell people? And we did touch on this earlier about, you're talking about the herd mentality about people and their anxiety. but what do you tell people in this in the book? Well, you know, one of the things that I say when people talk about investing emotions is that making money is not the goal of investing.
什么适合你？不仅仅是理解数字是什么。所以你的书里也有一整章关于管理投资情绪的内容。那么你告诉人们什么？我们之前确实提到了这一点，关于你谈论的羊群心态，关于人们和他们的焦虑。但你在书中告诉人们什么？嗯，你知道，当人们谈论投资情绪时，我所说的一件事是，赚钱不是投资的目标。
And some people hear that and they think I'm crazy, are the expression. And some people hear that and go absolutely right. The reason is this, all investing decisions are attempts to meet emotional goals or emotional needs. Investing is always a means to an end. And there's such a tendency to focus on the means and forget about the why. We talk about the what, what should I be in right now? How's Apple doing?
有些人听到这个会认为我疯了，或者这种表达。有些人听到这个会说绝对正确。原因是这样的，所有的投资决策都是为了满足情感目标或情感需求的尝试。投资永远是达到目的的一种手段。人们有一种倾向，专注于手段而忘记了为什么。我们谈论的是什么，我现在应该投资什么？苹果公司表现如何？
What about overseas investing? What's a reet? You know, is fixed income. All of that what is a worthy conversation, but the really important conversation is the why. What am I doing this for? And if you can establish that, the what flows naturally from it. So if you recognize that as long as you're, and actually this is something I talked to talk to financial advisors a lot about. As long as the conversation and your framework for looking
海外投资怎么样？什么是房地产投资信托基金（REIT）？你知道，固定收益是吗。所有这些“什么”都是值得讨论的，但真正重要的对话是“为什么”。我做这件事是为了什么？如果你能确定这一点，那么“什么”就会自然而然地从中产生。所以如果你认识到，只要你是——实际上这是我经常与财务顾问谈论的事情。只要对话和你审视
at investing with the client is around numbers. And that's your language. We're all very facile with that language. It's easy and it's important when it comes to this subject. But as long as you're looking at numbers, you're always going to be off center from the nerve center where people are really making their emotional decisions. And so you have to translate all of that into the meaning it's going to have in the life of the person and how they're going to feel. Because we have emotional needs and we have financial needs. And we always think we're investing for the financial needs. Not so.
投资的框架是围绕数字的。那是你的语言。我们都非常擅长那种语言。它很容易，而且在这个主题上很重要。但只要你看着数字，你就总是会偏离人们真正做出情感决策的神经中枢。所以你必须把所有这些转化为它在那个人的生活中将具有的意义，以及他们将会有什么感觉。因为我们有情感需求，我们也有财务需求。我们总是认为我们是为了财务需求而投资。并非如此。
That's a means to an end. That's really fascinating. And so what are some common investing traps people might fall into? Common investing. Oh, there's so many. A whole separate episode about that. Oh, my gosh. And I can tell you from experience.
那只是达到目的的一种手段。这真的很迷人。那么人们可能会陷入哪些常见的投资陷阱呢？常见的投资。哦，太多了。关于那个可以单独做一集。哦，天哪。我可以凭经验告诉你，
experience, I've suffered some injuries walking that road falling into a pit here or there or wandering off the path. So yeah, I mean, the investing traps, there's a lot of them. I think one of the biggest ones is this. You know, it's called anchoring. You anchor yourself psychologically and emotionally to some number, some baseline number that may or may not be appropriate. And one of the biggest anchors is the price you paid for an investment.
经验，我在走那条路时受过一些伤，掉进了一个又一个坑里，或者偏离了道路。所以是的，我的意思是，投资陷阱，有很多。我认为其中最大的是这个。你知道，它被称为锚定效应。你在心理和情感上把自己锚定在某个数字上，某个可能合适也可能不合适的基准数字上。而最大的锚之一就是你为一项投资支付的价格。
Let's just say for stocks. get into company XYZ at $100 a share. And then it starts to drift down. And it's kind of languishing. And the market is even going up. But your XYZ Corp, which you bought at 100, now it's around 90, it's drifting down. It's not going anywhere. And that chucklehead neighbor of yours is talking about how he's invested in Amazon and
我们假设是股票。以每股100美元的价格买入XYZ公司。然后它开始下跌。它有点萎靡不振。市场甚至在上涨。但你的XYZ公司，你以100美元买入，现在大约是90美元，它在下跌。它哪里也不去。而你那个笨蛋邻居在谈论他如何投资了亚马逊，
he's doubled his money over the past year. And now it's starting to grate on you that you still own XYZ Corp. Now, maybe the best thing for you to do is to get out. out of that investment. Or maybe the best thing to do is to hold on or buy more. All of those things might be the right way to approach it. But what a lot of people will do is say, I can't let go of it until I've made my money back.
他在过去一年里让他的钱翻了一番。现在你仍然拥有XYZ公司这件事开始让你感到恼火。现在，也许你最好的做法是退出那项投资。或者也许最好的做法是坚持持有或买入更多。所有这些可能都是处理它的正确方式。但很多人会做的是说，在我赚回我的钱之前，我不能放手。
It's something that people tend to call break-evenitis. And so what happens is you end up clinging to these positions that go down. And because you're meeting, you're not meeting your financial lead at this point, are you? The best financial decision objectively may be to do something completely different. But what you're doing is you're serving some emotional need not to be wrong, not to feel foolish, not to feel like a failure. And so you can't serve both of those. And so often people get trapped in positions.
这是人们倾向于称之为“回本病”（break-evenitis）的东西。所以发生的事情是你最终紧紧抓住这些下跌的头寸。因为你正在满足，你此时并没有满足你的财务需求，不是吗？客观上最好的财务决策可能是做完全不同的事情。但你正在做的是服务于某种情感需求，即不犯错，不感到愚蠢，不感到像个失败者。所以你不能同时服务于这两者。所以人们经常被困在头寸中。
And this is something I bet you people listening to this, if there anything like me can relate to. What ends up happening is that you end up sort of collecting these investing dust bunnies because you can't let go of them and they end up cluttering up your portfolio and you end up ending a bunch of owning your portfolio ends up being a whole bunch of down stocks that you cling to because you were so busy trying to break even on things or even engaging what's called the sunk cost fallacy which is something along the lines of well it's so far down now there's no point in selling it that is almost never that is almost never a good way to approach a position that people trap themselves in in bad investments and it really is painful and it really affects people and
这是我敢打赌听这个节目的人，如果他们像我一样，都能产生共鸣的事情。最终发生的事情是，你最终收集了这些“投资灰尘”，因为你无法放手，它们最终塞满了你的投资组合，你最终拥有的一堆投资组合最终是一堆下跌的股票，你紧紧抓住它们，因为你太忙于试图回本，甚至陷入了所谓的“沉没成本谬误”，这大致意思是，好吧，它现在跌得太深了，卖掉它没有意义，这几乎从来不是，这几乎从来不是处理人们陷入坏投资的头寸的好方法，这真的很痛苦，它确实影响人们，而且
we're all you know we're all cut out to do this it takes some real work and help to avoid doing it and that applies to so many things in life you think about clutter in your home or being in a bad relationship or a bad friendship or wow it's just like the parallels are just amazing sometimes I think of finances is just simply about simple economics and money, but it really is so much more. I mean, you're talking about like just wanting to hold on so much and cling to those investments that are not serving you anymore. Like, wow. Yeah. And you know what? That's true. And I think the relationship with people is a very apt one. You know, I mean, we're here talking about investing psychology. But if you just want to talk about, you know,
我们都是，你知道，我们都是这样被塑造的，避免这样做需要真正的工作和帮助，这适用于生活中的许多事情，你想到家里的杂物，或者处于一段糟糕的关系或糟糕的友谊中，或者哇，这种相似之处有时真是太惊人了，我有时认为财务仅仅是关于简单的经济学和金钱，但它确实远不止于此。我的意思是，你在谈论那种想要紧紧抓住那些不再为你服务的投资，就像，哇。是的。你知道吗？那是真的。而且我认为与人的关系是一个非常贴切的类比。你知道，我的意思是，我们在这里谈论投资心理学。但如果你只是想谈论，你知道，
relationships with other people, the same rules tend to apply. And, you know, I think, I think they can make very good examples and a great way to communicate what a person's doing in a way that they can understand and get out of, you know, when you make these parallels. You talked about fear. So my question is why people might be scared to invest and how do people move past that fear? So whether they're scared to jump in or scared to sell the stock that's not helping anymore, it's not doing anything good for them, how do you motivate people to move past that? You know, that is an issue. which a lot of financial advisors face.
与其他人的关系，同样的规则往往适用。而且，你知道，我认为，我认为它们可以成为很好的例子，以及一种很好的方式来交流一个人正在做的事情，以一种他们能理解并摆脱的方式，你知道，当你做出这些类比时。你谈到了恐惧。所以我的问题是为什么人们可能害怕投资，以及人们如何克服这种恐惧？所以无论他们是害怕跳进去，还是害怕卖掉不再有帮助、对他们没有任何好处的股票，你如何激励人们克服这种恐惧？你知道，那是一个问题，许多财务顾问都面临这个问题。
It's worth my noting, if I haven't done it earlier, that I don't give investing advice. That's not what I do. And nothing I'm saying here is investing advice, but I do work with people who do give investing advice. And when they have a client who is kind of stuck, they don't want to move, a lot of times it boils down to a sense of control.
值得我指出的是，如果我之前没有这样做过，我不提供投资建议。那不是我做的事情。我在这里说的任何话都不是投资建议，但我确实与提供投资建议的人一起工作。当他们有客户有点卡住，不想动弹时，很多时候这归结为一种控制感。
And there's a lot of different factors that go into it. Sometimes they're really not sure the right thing, You know, like what, you know, there's so many choices that they find themselves paralyzed by just the sheer amount of things they could do. And so many people are afraid of taking a wrong step that it's just easier for them not to take a step at all. And that's one of the biggest mistakes. So one of the best ways to address that is to help meet that sense of control, which is really like an antidote to investing anxiety. And start by maybe taking a small step. we talk about kind of jumping in.
这其中涉及许多不同的因素。有时他们真的不确定什么是对的，你知道，选择太多了，以至于他们仅仅因为可能做的事情太多而感到瘫痪。许多人害怕走错一步，以至于觉得根本不迈出那一步反而更容易。这是最大的错误之一。因此，解决这个问题最好的方法之一就是帮助满足那种控制感，这实际上就像是投资焦虑的解药。从迈出一小步开始，我们谈论的是那种“跳进去”的感觉。
Dip your toe in the pool. You don't have to jump in. And it'll make it easier to make subsequent decisions once you've started that process. Because you don't have to start the process anew. It's a matter of continuing something and using the emotional inertia to keep yourself going. But a sense of control is one of the – and it doesn't actually have to be real control. Here's the thing. People talk about the illusion of control in psychological literature.
先试水。你不必直接跳进泳池。一旦你开始了那个过程，后续的决策就会变得更容易。因为你不必从头开始。这只是一个持续进行的过程，利用情感惯性让自己保持前进。但控制感是其中之一——而且它实际上不一定是真实的控制。事情是这样的，心理学文献中人们谈论的是“控制的错觉”。
It's not actually being able to control everything because, let's face it, we don't have that kind of control over our investments. Markets do what they do. The Fed raises rates. We elect Donald Trump. We have, well, in that case, we decided that collectively, but individually we don't have the ability to decide these things. So we have to focus on what we can control. And that's where a good financial advisor will help the person do that. And that helps get people comfortable enough so that they can. begin to make the decisions they need to. And you talked about the importance of financial literacy, especially for younger people. Can you talk about that a little bit more? Yeah, I think this is a real problem.
这并不是说真的能够控制一切，因为面对现实吧，我们对投资并没有那种控制力。市场有其自身的运行规律。美联储加息，我们选出了唐纳德·特朗普。好吧，在这种情况下，是我们集体做出的决定，但个人并没有能力决定这些事情。所以我们必须专注于我们能控制的事情。这就是优秀的财务顾问可以帮助人们做到的地方。这有助于让人们感到足够舒适，从而开始做出他们需要的决定。你谈到了金融素养的重要性，特别是对年轻人而言。你能多谈谈这一点吗？是的，我认为这是一个真正的问题。
And I think it's been a real problem for a long time. You know, I'm older now. You know, I'm what you'd call middle-aged. You know, for all my life, I didn't have anybody teach me how to proceed in a responsible and planful way with my finance. And I remember when I got out of my counseling psychology program at University of Buffalo, I remember thinking, all right, I'm going to be getting a job, I'm going to be making money, and really having no clue. But I should be doing. All right. And that's somebody who actually was interested in this subject. I think that if we can begin to teach young people especially, because even little kids get this, even at a pretty young age, a lemonade stand, you know, people understand, you know, these concepts before, you know, before they're giving credit for it, we could help solve an awful lot of problems for this country. And if you take a look, I'm starting to get, I don't mean to get
而且我认为这长期以来一直是一个真正的问题。你知道，我现在年纪大了。你知道，我属于所谓的“中年人”。在我的一生中，没有人教过我如何以负责任和有计划的方式处理我的财务。我记得当我从布法罗大学的咨询心理学项目毕业时，我记得当时想：“好吧，我要找工作了，我要赚钱了”，但真的对该做什么毫无头绪。而那还是一个对这个主题感兴趣的人。我认为，如果我们能开始教育年轻人，特别是考虑到即使是小孩子也能理解这一点，即使在很小的年纪，比如柠檬水摊，你知道，人们在被认可之前就已经理解了这些概念，我们就能帮助这个国家解决很多问题。如果你看看，我开始变得，我不是想变得
political here, but if you take a look at all the entitlement programs and all that people are relying on the government for, it really strikes me that if you're able to give people, because who knows if all that stuff's going to be there. Everybody talks about Social Security. We just don't know if it's going to be solvent. That's just something that we'll have to find out all together. But it seems to me that more so than ever, the ability to appreciate simple concepts like avoiding debt, an appropriate use of credit cards, and saving, and the beauty that is compound interest for your investing are really not difficult concepts. And when learned at an early enough age, will make massive differences, not only in the lives of the
政治化，但如果你看看人们依赖政府的所有福利项目，我真的觉得，如果你能赋予人们能力——因为谁知道那些东西是否会一直存在呢？每个人都在谈论社会保障。我们只是不知道它是否会保持偿付能力。这只是我们必须共同去发现的事情。但对我来说，比以往任何时候都更重要的是，能够理解简单的概念，如避免债务、适当使用信用卡、储蓄，以及复利对投资的美妙之处，这些真的不是困难的概念。如果在足够早的年龄学习，将产生巨大的差异，不仅是在
individual people who put these into practice, but for the country as well. And I'd like to see a lot more of it in the school system and otherwise. It's a real interest of mine. And more than that, it's something I feel really passionately about. Yeah, somewhat like delaying gratitude, which I think is always a challenge for humans, probably in general, and the younger people, too, is like, when you invest and you save or you, you know, when it's your first job, you, even if you're not making a lot of money, you put a little bit of money into a 401k, it's, it's that delayed gratification of this is starting a nest egg. This is starting. something that will eventually help you in the future. It's so hard to see it when you're
将这些付诸实践的个人生活中，对国家也是如此。我希望在学校系统和其他地方看到更多这样的教育。这是我真正感兴趣的事情。不仅如此，这也是我充满热情的事情。是的，有点像延迟满足，我认为这对人类来说通常是一个挑战，可能对年轻人也是如此，比如，当你投资和储蓄时，或者当你刚开始第一份工作时，即使你赚的钱不多，你也会往401k里存一点钱，这就是那种延迟满足，这是在建立储蓄。这是在开始
22 and fresh out of college, but so many people I hear look back and they're like, oh, I wish I had done that because because of compounding interest as you spoke of and starting early and having 35 years of money in the system as opposed to starting when you're 30, where you have fewer years. If people actually saw the effect that time has on investing, like you said, maybe starting when you're 20 versus starting when you're 30, it would open their eyes and blow them away. I've yet to meet the person who sees what compound interest does and doesn't go, holy cow, I just had no idea that it was that powerful. And I think a lot of it's just cultural. It's difficult to save for basically most people. It's just part of the culture at this point. A great book on the
某件最终会在未来帮助你的事情。当你22岁刚大学毕业时，很难看到这一点，但我听到的很多人回首往事时都会说：“哦，我真希望我当时那样做了”，因为正如你所说的复利，以及尽早开始，让资金在系统中运行35年，而不是30岁才开始，那时你的年限就少了。如果人们真的看到了时间对投资的影响，就像你说的，也许20岁开始和30岁开始相比，这会让他们大开眼界，让他们感到震惊。我还没见过有人看到复利的作用后不惊叹的，他们会说：“天哪，我真不知道它有这么强大。”我认为这很大程度上是文化问题。对大多数人来说，储蓄基本上很困难。这在目前只是文化的一部分。一本关于这个主题的好书是
subject is the automatic millionaire. And it gets at how people don't even recognize the opportunities they have to save. They go, well, you know, I'll put some money away when. You know what? If you can actually form that habit young when you're talking about saving allowance or doing something with doing something with gift money that you got, if you can actually build that habit in at a young age, you will be, your life will be different. I mean, it will change your life like few other things. And I think part of it boils down to, you have to, you're not going to get, you're not going to get the extrinsic reward, right? The extrinsic reward is something that comes a long time. in the future. But you have to recognize the intrinsic reward, feeling good about making that decision.
《自动百万富翁》。它揭示了人们甚至没有意识到他们拥有的储蓄机会。他们会说：“好吧，你知道，我会存点钱，当……”你知道吗？如果你能在年轻时养成那种习惯，当你谈论存零花钱或用你得到的礼物钱做点什么时，如果你能在年轻时养成这种习惯，你的生活将会不同。我的意思是，它会像极少数事情一样改变你的生活。我认为部分原因归结为，你必须，你不会得到，你不会得到外在的奖励，对吧？外在的奖励是未来很久才会到来的东西。但你必须认识到内在的奖励，为做出那个决定而感到良好。
It ought to give you a sense of comfort, a sense of security, even perhaps a sense of pride, knowing that you're doing this and taking control of your life. And I think that's one of those things that needs to be instilled in people, that, yeah, it may feel like you're sacrificing. Maybe you don't go out to the same restaurant you would have. Maybe you know, maybe you cook food for yourself. Maybe you don't buy the toy you want, but you can, it's not the loss of those things. It's the gain of feeling really wonderful of watching this project grow and watching, watching your, you know, watching you build something, literally build something that'll be with you the rest of your life. Absolutely. I think it goes a long way just to saying to doing it when you're young,
它应该给你一种舒适感、一种安全感，甚至可能是一种自豪感，知道你正在这样做并掌控着你的生活。我认为这是需要灌输给人们的事情之一，即，是的，这可能感觉像是在牺牲。也许你不会去你本来会去的同一家餐馆。也许你知道，也许你自己做饭。也许你没有买你想要的玩具，但你可以，这不是失去那些东西。这是获得看着这个项目成长、看着、看着你的，你知道，看着你建立某样东西的绝妙感觉，字面上建立某样将伴随你余生的东西。绝对是这样。我认为在年轻时就开始做这件事大有裨益，
too. And I mean, we're, this is going off and we're in like the marketing angle, but we're bombarded with so many messages about spending money and buying things and loans and, you know, buying. things beyond our means that it's so difficult to know that you need to put money away. You know, I mean, and not even just, yeah, yeah, not even just in the stock market, but in your own savings account. So you have that, you know, that cushion, that ability. So you're not, you know, living paycheck to paycheck. If you can avoid it, obviously, there's extenuating circumstances for many people out there. But, you know, if you're living more of a comfortable life, you know, instead of maybe purchasing a new car, it's like, you know,
也是。我的意思是，我们，这有点偏离主题，我们进入了营销角度，但我们被关于花钱、买东西、贷款和，你知道，购买超出我们能力范围的东西的信息轰炸，以至于很难知道你需要存钱。你知道，我的意思是，甚至不仅仅是，是的，是的，甚至不仅仅是在股市，而是在你自己的储蓄账户里。这样你就有了，你知道，那个缓冲，那个能力。所以你不会，你知道，过着月光族的生活。如果可以避免的话，显然，对许多人来说有情有可原的情况。但是，你知道，如果你过着更舒适的生活，你知道，而不是购买一辆新车，就像，你知道，
why did I put that money into a, into my, savings account and invest in some other way. But it's so difficult to get beyond all the temptations that exist. Yep. No, it's true. You know, it's interesting. People actually know what they're supposed to do. I don't think they always recognize the opportunities they have and build the habits.
为什么我不把那笔钱存入我的储蓄账户并以其他方式投资呢？但要克服所有存在的诱惑太难了。是的。不，这是真的。你知道，这很有趣。人们实际上知道他们应该做什么。我不认为他们总是意识到他们拥有的机会并养成习惯。
They don't get the emotional leverage on themselves to execute what they know they ought to do. For example, I got two kids. One's nine, one's six. both of them know how to be healthy. How should you be healthy? Oh, well, you got to eat right and exercise. Exactly. Eat right and exercise.
他们没有在情感上激励自己去执行他们知道应该做的事情。例如，我有两个孩子。一个九岁，一个六岁。他们俩都知道如何保持健康。你应该如何保持健康？哦，好吧，你必须吃得健康并锻炼。没错。吃得健康并锻炼。
Everybody knows this. Children know this. And we have an obesity epidemic. Right. It's not education people need. Now, it may be when it comes to investing, knowing the right things to do, because that anxiety from not wanting to do it wrong
每个人都知道这一点。孩子们也知道这一点。但我们却有肥胖流行病。没错。人们需要的不是教育。现在，当涉及到投资时，知道正确的事情可能很重要，因为那种不想做错事的焦虑
and the uncertainty can prevent people from moving forward or not recognizing the opportunities they have to exercise what it would be, you know, good behaviors. People know you got to invest. You got to save money, invest for the future, buy and hold. Everybody knows this. They need help in doing it. And I think that if you can instill the right habits and help them take the right way of looking at things at a young age, it may not be quite the chore that it seems to be when you get a little bit older.
和不确定性会阻止人们前进，或者让他们无法认识到他们拥有的锻炼良好行为的机会。人们知道你必须投资。你必须存钱，为未来投资，买入并持有。每个人都知道这一点。他们需要帮助来执行。我认为，如果你能在年轻时灌输正确的习惯并帮助他们采取正确的看待事物的方式，当你年纪稍大时，这可能就不会像看起来那么繁琐了。
Absolutely. And I want to leave listeners with some tips about where they can learn more about investing basics in the stock market. So do you have any advice on where people should start to learn about all these topics we mentioned, like compounding interest, financial literacy topics, things like that? If you want a financial literacy book, there are a couple that come to mind. Beating the Street by Peter Lynch was a seminal book for me. It was fascinating.
绝对是这样。我想给听众留下一些关于他们可以在哪里了解更多股市投资基础知识的建议。所以你对人们应该从哪里开始学习我们提到的所有这些主题有什么建议吗？比如复利、金融素养主题等等？如果你想要一本金融素养书，有几本浮现在脑海中。彼得·林奇的《战胜华尔街》对我来说是一本开创性的书。它非常引人入胜。
And that one helped teach me how to analyze a balance sheet. So that's a bit more technical. But it's also very reasonable. The Money Game by Adam Smith is just a really fun read. Of course, you can always go online and get these things at different sites. I recommend talking to other people as well. But if you want like a nuts and bolts, how am I supposed to learn about the mathematics of investing? Beating the Street by Peter Lynch and also Beyond Fear and Greed.
那本书帮助我学会了如何分析资产负债表。所以这稍微有点技术性。但它也非常合理。《金钱游戏》作者亚当·史密斯，读起来非常有趣。当然，你总是可以上网在不同的网站上获取这些信息。我也建议与其他人交谈。但如果你想要那种基础的、我该如何学习投资数学的东西？彼得·林奇的《战胜华尔街》以及《超越恐惧与贪婪》。
Beyond Fear and Greed by Hirschephren is a great book that addresses some of that but really gets more at these sites. the behavioral finance of investing. Okay, perfect. Yeah, I'm actually writing these down for myself. Oh, they're great. Yeah. I mean, honestly, I think I mentioned it before, Automatic Millionaire by David Bach.
赫什·弗伦的《超越恐惧与贪婪》是一本好书，它解决了一些这方面的问题，但实际上更多地触及了这些网站。投资的行为金融学。好的，太完美了。是的，我实际上正在为自己写下这些。哦，它们很棒。是的。我的意思是，老实说，我想我之前提到过，大卫·巴赫的《自动百万富翁》。
That one is, I've given that book to multiple people. I just think that's a great place to start, and it addresses more the how than the what, but, you know, really great book. The information's out. there, Caitlin. I know, really. Yeah. It's the best time, it's the best time ever to actually learn about these things. But as we know, you know, having more information doesn't actually make you a better decision maker a lot of times. So there's an awful lot of work that has to go into understanding
那本书，我已经把它送给多个人了。我只是认为这是一个很好的起点，它更多地解决了“如何做”而不是“做什么”，但是，你知道，真的是一本好书。信息就在那里，凯特琳。我知道，真的。是的。这是学习这些事情的最佳时机。但正如我们所知，你知道，拥有更多信息并不能让你在很多时候成为更好的决策者。所以，在完全能够付诸实践所有那些伟大的信息之前，
yourself, you know, before you can fully put into practice all that great information that's out there. And going after reputable sources, like you said, like if you're seeing who the author of a book or a blog is too, is important too. That is someone who has a, you know, the background you think is, will give you, provide you with the best information. Yep. Yeah, absolutely. And like I said before, I think it's really important. You know, start your journey on yourself, but by yourself, but involve other people along
你必须对自己进行大量的了解。而且要寻找可靠的来源，就像你说的，比如查看一本书或博客的作者是谁也很重要。那是一个你认为拥有背景知识的人，会给你提供最好的信息。是的。是的，绝对是这样。就像我之前说的，我认为这真的很重要。你知道，开始你自己的旅程，但要涉及其他人
the way. It's really important to help get the perspectives of other people, and it'll help you develop your own perspectives. And do you have any final advice for investors as 2019 progresses? It reminds me, reminds me the end of the. of Hill Street Blues. I sign off my blog post this way a lot of times. Hey, let's be careful out there. Is that your advice? That would be my advice. I wouldn't give market advice. But you know what? You want something a little more concrete? I would say this. Have a plan. It can be a plan
一路上。获取他人的观点真的很重要，这将帮助你发展自己的观点。对于2019年的投资者，你有什么最后的建议吗？这让我想起，让我想起《希尔街的布鲁斯》的结尾。我很多时候都是这样结束我的博客文章的。嘿，在那边要小心。这是你的建议吗？那会是我的建议。我不会提供市场建议。但你知道吗？你想要更具体一点的东西吗？我会说这个。制定一个计划。它可以是一个
with contingencies, but have a plan. And there's some good reasons why. Not only will having a plan make it more likely that you can put into action behaviors that will help you. But at some point, we're really going to have a crisis. I don't think what we've experienced lately fully qualifies. It was scary and unnerving, but it's not a panic. But someday that panic's going to come, because it always comes. We just never know when. And when it does, when you have a plan, not only do you have steps you can take, but simply the value of having, you know, the security of knowing you have that plan is what keeps people from panicking in the moment. I mean, one of the things that I think is interesting is it's not necessarily,
带有应急预案的计划，但一定要有计划。这有几个很好的理由。不仅拥有计划会使你更有可能采取有助于你的行为。而且在某个时候，我们真的会遇到危机。我不认为我们最近经历的事情完全符合。它很可怕，让人不安，但不是恐慌。但总有一天恐慌会到来，因为它总是会来。我们只是不知道什么时候。当它到来时，当你有一个计划，你不仅有可以采取的步骤，而且仅仅是知道你有那个计划的安全感，就是防止人们在当下恐慌的原因。我的意思是，我认为有趣的事情之一是，它不一定是，
that the steps within a plan are optimal, that's great if they are. But the psychology of knowing when it happens, aha, I anticipated this, I am ready for it, I have things I can do. Very few things take back that so important sense of control, like taking in action. And when you have the ability to do that, all of these crises become, frankly, they become opportunities if you look at them the right way. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Murtha. It's been a pleasure having you on our show. So if people want to get in touch with you, how would they do that? Sure. I'd love that. Best way is probably my email. F. Murtha at Marketpsych. Great. Well, thank you so much. Thank you. Now is the time to share a listener letter.
计划中的步骤是最优的，如果它们是最优的那当然很好。但知道当它发生时，“啊哈，我预料到了这一点，我已经准备好了，我有可以做的事情”的心理学。很少有事情能像采取行动那样夺回那种重要的控制感。当你拥有这样做的能力时，所有这些危机都会变成，坦率地说，如果你以正确的方式看待它们，它们就会变成机会。非常感谢你加入我们，默萨博士。很高兴你能来我们的节目。所以如果人们想和你联系，他们该怎么做？当然。我很乐意。最好的方式可能是我的电子邮件。F. Murtha at Marketpsych。太棒了。好吧，非常感谢。谢谢。现在是分享听众来信的时间了。
This one's in regards to episode 70, how to cope with political discussions and keep it civil this holiday season. Before he passed away from cancer a few years ago, my partner was someone with very different political views to me, so I really enjoyed hearing from your guest. I didn't know any other couples who disagreed on political issues like we did, and we had to work around our differences, find common ground, and learn from each other. Disrespect or dismissal of conservative viewpoints by liberals, and vice versa is everywhere on TV, comedy, movies, lifestyle shows, documentaries, and in social situations where agreement is just assumed. But I hadn't seen my own side's culpability before meeting my partner and it opened my eyes and made me realize how important it was to keep
这一封是关于第70集，如何在假期期间应对政治讨论并保持文明。在几年前因癌症去世之前，我的伴侣是一个政治观点与我非常不同的人，所以我真的很喜欢听你的嘉宾的分享。我不知道还有其他像我们这样在政治问题上有分歧的夫妇，我们必须解决我们的分歧，找到共同点，并互相学习。自由派对保守派观点的不尊重或排斥，反之亦然，在电视、喜剧、电影、生活方式节目、纪录片以及默认达成一致的社交场合中随处可见。但在遇到我的伴侣之前，我没有看到我自己这一方的过错，这让我大开眼界，让我意识到保持
things civil on both sides. Thanks for the great podcast, lots of useful tips on how to have good relationships and manage tricky discussions. Thank you for your note and for listening. If you have any comments or questions for us, again, email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-R. Also, if you've been a longtime listener or are new to our show, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes, or if you have time, write a review. we'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue
双方文明是多么重要。感谢这个很棒的播客，有很多关于如何建立良好关系和管理棘手讨论的实用技巧。感谢你的来信和收听。如果你有任何意见或问题，再次，请发邮件给我，K-Luna at APA.org。那是K-L-U-N-A-A-A-R。此外，如果你是我们的长期听众或者是新听众，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分，或者如果你有时间，写一篇评论。我们将不胜感激。Speaking of Psychology是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他很棒的播客，如APA期刊对话
about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org, to listen to more episodes and to see resources on the topics we discuss.
关于新的心理学研究和心理学实践的进度记录。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站，speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看我们讨论主题的资源。
I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。